we're gonna need more diapers diapers
very something you've been meaning to
tell us what No
this kid is not my grandson from the
future or any when heck iris and I don't
even have kids um Barry what I am
pregnant what I found out this morning I
was gonna tell you tonight in private
hi dad hi aunt dawn wait there - in
there
we're having twins spoilers Bartholomew
Henry Alan that's not a good name look
are you sure I don't bark you can bark
feels more natural to me
can we go with Barton bars kind of cool
Your Honor I miss I didn't do this I
didn't kill anyone he didn't do those
things
my mom I was there that night there was
a man plan hey everybody
this house is bitchin so everybody was
wondering about Barry's gibberish there
were a couple really big Easter eggs
four notable comic book things like Bart
Allen their tornado twins in the
reverse-flash in all that craziness but
all said there were about fourteen
different things that he mentioned
including the ones that I'm put in that
clip those are just the biggest ones so
that's what I'm gonna focus on in this
video but I'll read off the rest of the
jibberish sayings at the end of this and
explain what I think that they mean
there is a new round or that Justice
League ticket giveaway - all you have to
do to enter is be a subscriber and leave
a comment on this video so most of you
probably picked up on a couple of the
easier gibberish sayings like when he
had that line from Oliver I don't think
I'm like you Oliver I'm just not sure
I'm like you Oliver that's a direct call
back to this scene from the pilot
episode where he went to Oliver to get
some sage wisdom about what to do now
that he had all these crazy abilities
but a lot of you probably guessed
correctly based on the really easy
things to decode like we need more
diapers obviously talking about future
children that'll be coming down the road
is is that Cisco's algorithm did work
it's just that it's a line of dialogue
that someone's not going to utter until
a future episode so for the sake of
simplicity let's assume that 99.9% of
all the dialogue that's from future
episodes is from the future of this
season so we're gonna need more diapers
implies that somebody's going to say
that before the finale or in the finale
because that feels like a really big
thing to end on like holy crap are they
actually gonna have kids in season five
that'd be ridiculous
but when he says things like dad and I
are both okay we're both going to be
fine he's talking about this moment from
the season one finale when he got to say
goodbye to his mother that's what that
dialogue is from so all the gibberish is
either something that's going to happen
this season in the future or it's
something that happened in a previous
season so just limit yourself to that
but when he talks about the stars
raining that could be the crisis event
and that's not supposed to happen till
like season 10 based on their dates but
what they're telling us is is that they
will eventually get pregnant they'll do
tornado twins but we don't know what
that's gonna look like there
so many problems with trying to do
babies especially twin babies on a
network TV show that's about a superhero
like Oliver is having enough trouble
with William this season on arrow I
think it would be a nightmare to try and
work with babies on the flash so I have
a feeling they'll have some story
solution to that so that they can do the
babies but then you won't have to deal
with them every single week like they'll
have to be sent into the future or
something crazy will happen but it all
leads to Bart Allen so if you're worried
about children on the flash just
remember this you cannot get Bart Allen
on the show the thing that everybody's
been asking for without the twins so
that's just one step in the path to
getting him on that's why when Cisco
said this house is bitchin I wondered
which of the characters on the show
actually talks like that
even Cisco who has some pretty cringy
dialogue every once in a while doesn't
talk like that so unless they write some
really bad Cisco dialogue for a future
episode that sounds like something that
Bart Allen would say if you're a big fan
of the comics you may remember 90s Bart
Allen he actually did talk just like
that so I'm just leaving this house is
bitchin and we're gonna need more
diapers as an open Easter Egg for future
Bart Allen stuff but obviously they have
to do tornado twins before that moving
into reverse-flash territory so there
are a couple times in Barry's gibberish
that he mentions reverse-flash related
things one of them is actually a little
clearer than the other the first time he
says your honor I'm innocent
I didn't do this I didn't kill anyone
the second time he says he didn't do
those things he didn't hurt my mom I was
there that night there was a man that's
him saying a line of dialogue that he
had as a child while he was at his
father's trial when he was being falsely
accused of the murder of Nora Allen
remember they didn't know anything about
reverse-flash at the time Barry was the
only person who saw the man in yellow
and it became that lifelong obsession
for him until it culminated in the
season one arc but that first time you
may remember Barry when he went back to
save his mother in the season 1 finale
he saw those flashes of the future your
honor I'm innocent I didn't do this I
didn't kill anyone might be a reference
to something from this season for this
moment here so all the things that
they've shown in this big flashback from
season one they've done
having quite got to flash museum yet
they just paid off killer frost in
season 2 and now season 3 and 4 and then
we haven't gotten to this prison get up
yet the thing that everyone's pointing
to is that it is sort of an easter egg
for the trial of the flash because he
killed the reverse-flash Zod style by
snapping his neck to save him from
killing his girlfriend eventually he was
acquitted but it was a really seminal
flash story he actually killed his
greatest enemy and it's one of the
things that he regrets most because the
flash doesn't kill people even though a
lot of you will point out that he
actually killed someone at the beginning
of season 2 so even though Barry doesn't
kill people he's actually killed a
couple people but those are really the
only Easter eggs that I think we've seen
of the reverse-flash so far a lot of you
have asked me if I think that maybe this
isn't Barry's that came back from the
Speed Force and it's just reverse flash
that looks like Barry he's just
disguised himself I don't think that's
the case I think it's genuinely supposed
to be Barry and that's why you have this
moment with Iris at the end where he's
like I'll always come back to you but
there was a short arc in the comics
where eobard thawne came into the past
masquerading as Barry Allen and people
thought that he'd come back from the
dead it was a long time before flash
rebirth so he'd still been lost into the
Speed Force it was prime Wally West
flash era so I can see why people
thought that that might be what they're
doing but because the tone is supposed
to be a lot lighter I think they're not
playing this in the cynical way if it
was a much darker story then I would say
definitely for sure this is reverse
flash pretending to be Barry but because
of all these scenes here where he's
celebrating his bachelor party where
he's in therapy with iris where he's
trying to learn how to become part of
the group again after being gone for so
long that all seems very heartfelt
it doesn't ring false to me so I think
that this is Barry Allen and when you
bar Thawne does come back it'll be a
little bit different but it's sort of
the same thing with the idea of them
bringing bart allen on the TV show
they've been adamant about how they're
not going back to the speedster well
right away so if they do any of that
kind of stuff it'll be the back half of
the season and they'll ease into it and
it still won't overpower their think or
arc he's still gonna be the big villain
of the season it's gonna be a much more
thriller detective based story that's
why they're bringing the elongated man
on because he's a detective from the
comics so it'll be Barry learning how to
use his powers in ways beyond just
running really fast but let me know in
the comments speedforce prophet Barry
said more diapers
there will be babies when do you think
that they'll actually pay that off do
you think that it's gonna be a moment in
the finale because right at the end of
the thinker arc in the comics Wally
Weston and Linda learned that they were
pregnant with twins it came right after
they defeated the thinker so it just
feels like the perfect holy [ __ ] oh my
god moment to end season 4 on but what
will happen tomorrow is is I think I
have a pretty good idea of when titans
is going to premiere next year so I
might do a Titans video before I start
doing more flash but whole bunch of
flash episode 2 I'll name the giveaway
winner when I post my next DC video so
you can click here for all my episode 1
episode 2 videos and you can click here
to re-watch that Black Panther trailer
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight